if you look at us as a species we're not
very impressive what we're good at is
forming complex social networks the
purpose of human sexuality the function
is social it's not reproductive hi I'm
fed Russell for recent TV today I'm
joined by Christopher Ryan Christopher
Ryan with his wife castled ajaita is the
author of sex at dawn how we mate why we
stray and what it means for modern
relationships I'm interested in freedom
many of our listeners and Watchers are
interested in freedom what does your
book offer to someone who wants more
freedom in their lives well it offers a
way to sort of fight their way out of
socially imposed restrictions on not so
much on behavior necessarily but on
desires
it was Schopenhauer I think who said the
man can control what he does but not
what he wants to do and so a lot of our
desires are very deeply ingrained in our
evolutionary past particularly the
desire or the attraction to multiple
people which is one of the central
points we make in the book so if you're
in a long-term relationship with someone
that's sexually monogamous but you're
interested in other people you're
attracted to other people that doesn't
mean there's anything wrong with your
marriage necessarily or your
relationship or that there's anything
wrong with you or your partner so there
are different levels of freedom of
course there's freedom of action but
there's also freedom of thought and
desire and I think those are the sorts
of freedoms that our book speaks to so
marriage certainly is a central pillar
in our culture everyone agrees on that
and monogamy of course is central to
marriage right and there are something
like 1500 rights benefits and privileges
granted to married couples that others
don't get right so it's it's really
important in our culture and it's
enforced by the state
what is your thesis doing to that pillar
well first it questions the premise that
month that sexual monogamy is central to
marriage we look at many different
societies around the world that practice
what anthropologists in any case call
marriage in which sexual monogamy is not
essential aspect of that really
we look at societies in which property
rights are not involved with marriage in
which assumptions of continuity or
childcare or you know any of these other
things that we associate with marriage
certainly property rights is a big part
of marriage in our society now
anthropologists who say marriage is a
human Universal are applying this term
to all sorts of relationships that
really have no connection no
relationship with or no you know
resonance with our Western sense of
marriage there are societies in the
Amazon for example that believe that an
infant or a fetus I should say is
literally made of accumulated semen and
so women in these societies who want to
have a child who is funny and smart and
good-looking make sure they have sex
with the funny guy and the smart guy and
the good-looking guy and then went to
get the essence of each of these men
into the the fetus and then when the
child is born each of these men will
come forward and acknowledge their
paternity
so even paternity is not a universally
understood concept much less what
anthropologists and others are calling
marriage
okay so monogamy is not universal now
what is your evidence to demonstrate
that monogamy has never been a universal
well we look at four basic sources of
information in the book the Anthropology
is one of them so we're looking at
societies particularly pre agricultural
societies that presumably have a lot in
common with our pre agricultural
ancestors because of the structural
similarities that you find in pre
agricultural societies all around the
world
we know our ancestors lived as nomadic
hunter-gatherers until about 10,000
years ago at most when agriculture first
seems to have appeared in the Fertile
Crescent so that's one source of
information we also look at primates
particularly the primates closest to
humans chimps and bonobos we look at the
other Apes as well but try to focus on
on the primates that are most closely
related to
we look at human anatomy our bodies tell
us a great deal about the way our
ancestors behaved sexually our genitalia
the fact that we have external testicles
the fact that women are capable of
multiple orgasm whereas men aren't
generally you know and then we look at
contemporary psycho sexuality the sorts
of problems people have in long term
relationships the sorts of fetishes or
sexual issues that bring people to
therapists all these different sources
of information converge on a vision of
so-called natural human sexuality or at
least sexuality that is resonant with
the way our ancestors lived that is a
pretty cohesive vision of the way we
evolve okay let's start with bonobos I
didn't I didn't know what bonobos were
until I read your book so it sounds to
me like bonobos can set us free why is
that
well Fran's Duvall who is the the one of
the greatest living primatologists who
has written extensively on both bonobos
and chimpanzees said that chimpanzees
use violence and power games to get sex
whereas bonobos use sex to avoid
violence so they're two very different
approaches to social organization that
sort of hinge on their relationship to
sexuality know what's interesting people
don't understand people say you know if
someone who has a lot of sex they say
well you know they're they're like
animals actually animals would be
embarrassed by our behavior human beings
have sex about a thousand times per
birth the average among mammals is about
a dozen times per birth right so we're
off the charts there are very few
animals very few mammals particularly
that have sex when the female is not
ovulating right human beings have sex
when the females already pregnant when
she's menstruating when she's lactating
when she's postmenopausal we have oral
sex anal sex all types of sex that can't
possibly lead to conception that's
vanishingly rare among
animals so the first thing to understand
about human sexuality is that it's not
primarily about reproduction as
counterintuitive as that may sound the
vast majority of our sexual interactions
have nothing whatsoever to do it's
almost like reproduction is a
an occasional byproduct of human
sexuality the purpose of human sexuality
the function is social it's not
reproductive and that's something that
we have very deeply in common with
bonobos bonobos use sex as a way as a
social lubricant as a way to maintain
equilibrium as a way to avoid conflicts
that would threaten the cohesion of the
group if all the males are having sex
with females pretty much whenever anyone
wants to there's much less to fight
about right whereas the mainstream view
of human evolution holds that we sort of
evolved in these independent nuclear
families where the man would go out and
hunt and then bring home the dead deer
and share it only with his wife and his
children because he was concerned with
his paternity it turns out that's not
the way hunter-gatherers live and
certainly isn't the way our closest
primate relatives live so I'm interested
in social control especially control of
sexuality so I mean in our culture you
know generally speaking we've been told
that sex outside of marriage is bad and
the argument behind that is that sex is
about reproduction so that if you're not
having reproductive sex you're doing
something that's essentially unnatural
and now it sounds to me like you're
intervening there and yeah that's that's
[ __ ] that there's no scientific
credibility at all behind that statement
I know it's commits it's a very central
statement to particularly the right wing
vision of sexuality and certainly the
Catholic Church's vision of sexuality
but if you have any understanding at all
of the anthropological or private
illogical research you see that that's
ridiculous and also just to interject
quickly that you know that's the kind of
thinking that led to the war on
masturbation in which you know little
girls were having
carbolic acid poured onto their clitoris
to stop them from touching themselves
and and young boys were having their
foreskin sewn together with
you know metal threads and stuff this
was early 20th century this wasn't very
long ago you know or electroshock
therapy to solve the problem of the
sickness of homosexuality which was
happening as late as the 1960s and 70s
so that idea that sex is only for
reproduction leaves out the vast
majority of the things we we do either
alone or with other people sexually you
know we use the word promiscuity in our
book but we're very careful to explain
that we use it in the original sense the
the roots of the word mean to mix and we
argue that our ancestors were
promiscuous in the sense that they very
likely had several ongoing sexual
relationships at any given point in
their adult lives but we're not saying
we're not using it in the modern sense
where our ancestors certainly weren't
having sex with strangers why there were
no strangers right our ancestors lived
in very intimate bands with no more than
150 people we can talk about how we know
that number Rob it's Dunbar's number
interesting sidenote
but generally about 150 people or fewer
they're raising one another's kids
together you know the kids call every
woman mom and every man dad you know
they're the very intimate relationships
so yes they were having sex with more
than one person at a time that's
virtually certain judging by the the
evidence that I've seen but it wasn't
cheap casual you know go to a bar meet
someone have sex never see them again
kind of sex right these are people who
were very close to one another who were
very interdependent talk about a little
bit more about the what I take is the
the inner civil war between a chimp and
a bonobo inside each of us if you go to
a zoo and you're looking at a chimp or a
bonobo in a cage consider the fact that
you're more closely related to that
animal than that animal is to anything
else in the zoo chimp or a bonobo is
more closely related to a human than an
Indian elephant is to an African
elephant we're extremely in terms of DNA
last common ancestor all the scientific
ways of judging
these things we're extremely closely
related in fact Jared Diamond in one of
his books argues that really
scientifically speaking were three
subspecies of chimpanzee so the bonobo
is wonderful peaceful no bonobo has ever
been witnessed to kill or rape another
bonobo there's never been a case a
witness case though infanticide this is
an in captivity or in the wild in over
50 years of quite intense observation
whereas the chimps are very can be very
aggressive can be aggressive in an
organized way that some primatologists
refer to as war where one band will
attack another band and kill the male's
to take over their territory and all
this sort of thing but even with
chimpanzees I think that argument is
quite overstated by people like Steven
Pinker and others who argue for the
primate origins of warfare because what
you find for example in the most famous
case of Jane Goodall's work in Gombe the
first twelve years I believe that she
was at Gombe observing the chimps she
never saw any of that sort of warfare
there were very few cases of one chimp
maybe killing a young chimp or something
like that but though organized warfare
and all that came about when she started
supplying bananas in one place at one
time of day and that's when she started
to observe lots of aggression much more
coalitional conflict between groups of
males other groups coming in and
attacking the local group and so on so
what did she do she created an
agricultural situation among those
chimps she wasn't doing it on purpose of
course she just thought they'd made more
sense for observation to have the chimps
come in it was at the competition for
the Baudette bananas that you're
positing is the cause of war it changed
the the ecological situation in a way
that made war suddenly worthwhile
because there was a concentrated
predictable source of food there was
accumulated resources we could say if
you've got a
crate of bananas at 5:00 p.m. every day
that Springs open and the same place
every day every you know it's
predictable then there's a reason to set
up and stay there so you find this in
hunter-gatherer people as well you know
there are two sort of classic divisions
immediate return hunter-gatherers and
delayed return on tour gathers immediate
return under gathers are nomadic you eat
pretty much what you caught or found
today because there's no refrigeration
or anything like that you're not storing
food but then you've got delayed return
hunter-gatherers like in the area around
the Seattle Vancouver the northwest
where even though they didn't really
have agriculture they did have
predictable seasonal surplus of food the
salmon runs and what you find is that
those types of societies tend to be very
warlike and aggressive why because
there's something worth fighting over
there's something worth defending there
smoking the salmon they've got
accumulated stores of salmon so it's
almost an agricultural situation how is
monogamy as a cultural norm attached to
the rise of Agriculture well
monogamy is essentially a way of
assuring paternity by the way when we
talk about monogamy until very recently
I'm talking within the last couple of
decades we were really only talking
about women women's sexual behavior if
you look at Daltrey in the Bible you
know there's tons of male adultery right
the the only adultery anybody would get
stoned for involved a married woman
concubine slaves unmarried women do what
you want right there's no problem there
it says thou shalt not covet thy
neighbor's wife nor his house nor his ox
nor his slaves nor his she a set cetera
so it's don't covet thy neighbor's stuff
part of his stuff is his wife right so
the connection between monogamy as
control of women's sexuality and
property is very essential in profound
the reason is paternity certainty that
men want to know who's that those
children are his right I want to know
those kids are mine why because I'm
leaving my farm I'm leaving my
yes I'm leaving my ox I'm leaving all my
stuff to those kids so the the the
essential importance of paternity
certainty we argue in in sexathon
relates to property rights not to human
nature because if you don't have any
property or all the property is shared
among the group then who gives a damn
whose kids those are biologically
speaking so is there a way to have a
society in which we have property rights
and private property but we don't
enforce the norms of monogamy and the
nuclear family well sure I mean we've
got birth control right so we no longer
need to control a woman's sexual
behavior to assure paternity we no
longer need to marry a virgin to be sure
that any children she produces
subsequently will be ours you know what
I mean all these things you know date
back to a time when there were no DNA
tests there were no condoms there was no
birth control pill all these things
didn't exist so the only way to assure
paternity was to have absolute control
over a woman's behavior and we still see
this this sort of behavior in these
sorts of sorts of social structures in
many parts of so but there's no
necessary connection between private
property and monogamy no not at this
point certainly because of Technology
because of Technology and heritance laws
yeah
birth control yeah why is that important
for us why does it matter in our lives
today because we're all perverts
sexuality is a very important part of
most people's lives and a very important
part of intelligence is an attraction to
novelty right we like new kinds of music
we like new shows new movies new colors
and new art you know we're always
interested in novelty because it's
interesting it's inherently interesting
to intelligent beings that applies to
our sexuality as well this stuff is
important because it takes away the
guilt it takes away the shame it shows
that this attraction to novelty is
certainly natural homosexuality once you
understand that sex isn't about
reproduction
and then suddenly the you know the
argument that homosexuality is is God
didn't intend it because it doesn't
create babies well that's an empty
argument that's that's no argument at
all most sex doesn't create babies
99.99% of sex doesn't create babies
right so I think if we could subvert
this assumption that sex is about
creating babies then suddenly a lot of
things start to fall apart things that
deserve to fall apart in my opinion I
certainly don't mean to say when I argue
that you know attraction to novelty no
I'm not saying that there's no sexual
behavior that should be condemned you
know there certainly are I mean rape and
pedophilia and all sorts of any sort of
coercive sexual behavior is to be
condemned I think but whether or not
these things are natural it's very
complicated to say you know one of the
interesting differences between men and
women involves erotic plasticity so
there's some interesting research using
devices that measure genital blood flow
that seems to indicate that men know
what turns them on and women often don't
women there will often be a schism
between or a split between what how
their body is responding to something
whether it be a video or images or
whatever a story and what she will
report consciously it doesn't mean she's
necessarily lying it's just that the her
ability to gauge how her body's
responding to things isn't always as as
clear as it is for most males what's
your position on jealousy if I feel
jealous what should I think about that
well I think you should think about
you're the source of your insecurity
right I think jealousy is an expression
of insecurity and fear and in that sense
sure it's natural right all animals feel
fear of losing something that's valuable
to them whether it's a shelter or or
they're lazy bruh they just killed or
their life or their maid or whatever you
know so in that extent it's it's
it's natural but the way different
societies minimize or amplify that
response so you've got some societies
like the most oh we talked about in
southwestern China who hold that sexual
jealousy or any kind of move toward
possession of another person or control
of another person is seen as pathetic
and ridiculous and highly offensive so
in that society you don't see much of
that you just see very little of that
whereas in societies like ours I think
our society plays that up plays up the
possession because it's it's congruent
with our economic and social structures
I can imagine that some people would
criticize your book as being simply an
excuse for people like Anthony Weiner
the book is about authenticity it's
about open communication it's about
coming out of the closet whatever your
closet happens to be and facing who we
are as individuals and as a species
starting from that sort of authenticity
whether it's in our marriage or in just
in our own essence know thyself right
Socrates so certainly our book is not at
all about giving excuses to cheaters and
liar there are a lot of marriages in
which these sorts of agreements have
been made and there is some integrity
and authenticity within the marriage if
a public person is in that sort of a
marriage and something comes up I would
just love to see someone say on 60
minutes or on the nightly news or
whatever it's nobody's business my wife
knows my kids know everybody knows it
I've got nothing to be ashamed of we all
love each other what's your problem I'm
looking forward to a day where people
say you know what the people I love the
people I know who know me have no
problem with the way I'm living my life
if you do then don't vote for me or
don't find my product or gone watch me
golf or whatever it is that's your
decision
but I'm okay with the way I'm living my
for some people that means strictly
enforced monogamy for other people it
doesn't one of the great things I
learned when researching the book I went
to find the first example of mate
swapping behavior or open marriages in
the US and I thought it was gonna be
hippies you know and and in fact I found
that it was world war two fighter pilots
who had the highest fatality rates of
any division of the military when they
were back on base they had these key
parties where they would sleep with one
another's wives and in interviews with
these people what we found was that they
said he wasn't really about sex we could
have sex with anyone we wanted you know
we were fighter pilots and their their
wives and girlfriends were obviously
very attractive people these are all top
guns right the reason they were doing
this was to create bonds affiliation
love among the group because 25 percent
of these guys didn't survive the war and
they knew they were facing those odds
and they knew that if they didn't come
home their buddies would take care of
their wives and children because they
had developed this love and trust and
that to me echoed so closely with the
the evidence of our ancestors that sex
isn't just about pleasure it's not just
about getting off it's about
establishing trust commitment
understanding social bonds that keep us
alive that's what we do better than any
other species what is the natural state
of human beings to be as similar as
saying what's the natural state of h2o
right it depends we can be a solid under
some pressure and temperature we can be
a liquid we can be got you know it
depends so I think we certainly are
capable there's no question that we're
capable of extreme violence and cruelty
right but we're also capable of extreme
generosity and and kindness to me I look
at our society and I say wow there's an
awful lot of training for violence
there's an awful lot of
social pressure to move us toward the
the violent edge of the scale and one of
the things one of the most effective
ways of making a society violent is to
be very restrictive of sexuality by the
way interesting particularly for
adolescent males there's all sorts of
research there you know and everyone
talks about the fact that you know you
can kill all the people you want on TV
you just can't have sex with one you
know that if there's something
interesting going on there in terms of
the way with what we present to children
and adults even but for me one of the
interesting things is you know there's
no nobody's walking around suffering
from PTSD because they helped a stranger
right but we've got all these veterans
coming back from these pointless wars we
send them off to suffering lifelong
debilitating mental illness because of
the things they saw or did that tells me
something right chimps don't get PTSD
because they ripped a monkey apart so if
Steven Pinker and others are gonna say
we're much more like chimps how do they
explain PTSD how do they explain you
know the the extreme suffering that
results in in most cases from being
cruel to other human beings you know
even Psychopaths there there aren't a
lot of Psychopaths but what we generally
find with pedophilia and in other forms
of extreme aggression is that those
people are victims they were victims as
children they're not typical healthy
individuals who go off and do these
things so yeah human nature is variable
but I do think that all things being
considered we tend to align much more
with bonobos so we can make love and not
war well I think the more love we make
the less war we'll make but you are
hopeful I'm hopeful yes and it seems
that the arc of history is you know it
points toward greater freedom and
acceptance certainly in the last 10-15
years we've seen acceptance of same-sex
marriage just go from one end of the
spectrum to the other so I think the
momentum is with us yes well good well
thank you very much for joining us I
want to thank Chris
for Ryan for being with us today for
reason TV I'm fat Russell
[Music]